[Music]
today's question comes from andrew in
oklahoma my girlfriend and i met in
college and have been dating for four
years i left school for a great job in
i.t in school i didn't know what i
wanted to do but realized when i took
this job that it is my passion my
girlfriend just started optometry school
which is three hours away and wants me
to move there and get married i want to
get married but this dream job just fell
in my lap and i'm having a hard time
giving it up i think a long distance
relationship can work and i'm willing to
get married after she finishes school
and gets a full-time job is it selfish
of me to want to keep my job for now hey
doc i'm gonna let you take a shot first
and then i'll i'll swoop in if uh if i
feel necessary i've got thoughts i
what do you think relationship guru so i
don't think this is a
job issue
i think somebody wants to get married
now and somebody wants to get married
later i
well well diagnosed and so
i think there's a relationship
that is much more rocky than the
previous four years might might let on
and we've come to a fork in the road i
don't recommend dating for seven years
three of those being long distance one
of you in grad school and one of you
working your dream job
um
this is a conversation that's not it's
gonna end up being a fight about school
or a fight about my dream job that's not
it
the conversation here is about our
relationship that's what i think
yeah i i i don't think it's fair
and i don't mind you disagreeing with me
on this i don't think it's fair for her
to put that pressure on him
to move to where she's going to school
not where she's going to work but where
she's going to score everything
temporary for her to say hey i need you
to leave this thing that you love it's a
big part of of what you're doing and who
you are now right
i just think it's unfair for her to to
ask that
and vice versa right she gets into yeah
it's not right for him to go no you
can't go to get your dream yeah i agree
with that my my thinking here is um
man
i've just is this the only optometry
school that she can go to
we don't know we don't have a job
there's not i.t jobs somewhere else in
hotel right so yeah that's where you're
gonna have this impasse together
if somebody gets into med school and my
first thought is well what about me
that's a signal that you're not on the
same page relationally right wow um
tough yeah so my wife had a great job
and and that she loved and great
community there in texas and when i got
this job in nashville at the university
it was
i can't i can't wait to see what this
adventure is going to be right and it
was it would have been the same she got
some great opportunity tomorrow then it
would be about how can we do this thing
together not what about what about me
what about me so yeah they got to figure
out the together first that's right and
then the job stuff it tends to take care
of itself yep not always but maybe yeah
it's good